it's sort of the driving force of
innovation and economic growth and and
before I came up with this idea I mean
there was a lot of really smart people
thinking about this change from an
industrial society you know an old blue
collar manufacturing driven stealin
autos kind of economy to a post
industrial economy and people like Dan
Bell the great sociologist at Columbia
and then at Harvard wrote a lot about
this and then of course Peter Drucker
you know probably one of the greatest
Bannock probably the greatest management
think of all time kind of dubbed this
group of people him and a guy named
Fritz malcham in the 50s dubbed this
group of people knowledge workers and
the idea was that people work with
knowledge they accumulate knowledge
economist talked about developing
education in human capital and I was
winning in Pittsburgh at the time
teaching at Carnegie Mellon and I was
looking at just like you and others
developments in the internet and
technology and I noted this kind of
thing with content and software and then
I began to see the role of arts and
music and remember I remember going to
England one time and this guy asked me a
question about software development and
biotech clusters I looked at him I said
who are the richest people in England
always like that's Paul McCartney and
Mick Jagger so I said there's something
with arts and music and entertainment
it's something with technology something
with knowledge workers what do they all
have in common and one day I was reading
some psychology and they were talking
about human creativity this guy Rob
sternberg wrote if you're an
entrepreneur or a business leader an
artist or a musician to design something
like that you're a creative person I
said oh my god maybe it's not just a
knowledge class or a post-industrial
class maybe this thing that links these
people together like the blue collar
worker used physical labor and the
factory maybe you think that links these
people together is their creativity so
we went back and we counted them with a
great group of researchers at Carnegie
Mellon and we first counted them across
cities and then we said we're going to
go back 100 years and count this group
of people and what we saw is that over
the past hundred years but certainly
since 1980 this group was really
expanding and just to give folks the
numbers between 1980 and today even with
the crisis we added 20 million new jobs
in the creative sector economy that
science technology arts entertainment a
filmmaking design and then the knowledge
workers right healthcare practitioners
lawyers those financial people who cause
part of this problem and in a
in the United States that's about a
third of the workforce more or less and
in this creative class even though they
make up a third of the workforce if you
add up all the wages and salaries we pay
in the United States and you divide it
into three groups right the
manufacturing working class the people
who do services lower end services you
know work weight on you in restaurants
sell your clothes take care of your
house and then the creative class the
creative class already accounts for more
than fifty percent and the other thing
just wrote folks watching we've actually
tracked the unemployment situation and
it's quite devastating in some respect
while the overall US unemployment rate
is ten percent and and while
manufacturing workers have unemployment
rates fifteen percent and in some parts
like extraction and construction 25% the
creative class is about five percent so
the creative class has never seen Brett
great swings I mean that's up from two
percent before it's never seen these
great volatility and swings that really
devastate manufacturing and and so I
think as we come out of this crisis
we're going to again see that this group
is more stable this group of jobs is
more stable and they're going to grow
again
the crisis is kind of the inflection
point or the transformation point you
know if you look back at the two
previous crises and and I'm actually
writing a book on this it's called the
great reset and hopefully you'll invite
me back to talk about how it comes out
in a name for my bed but if you look
back on previous crises they've always
been associated with the rise of new
economic systems so the crisis is 1873
was associated with the rise of you know
the first Industrial Revolution and it
gave rise to the second the crisis in
the 1930s was the rise of the Second
Industrial Revolution in these big steel
companies and auto companies and then we
figured out how to make the society work
this is really a crisis not just the
financial markets and wanted spending
and too much credit it's a tectonic
crisis that's associated with the rise
of a new economic order and what we were
doing is because we didn't know how to
invest in it we were speculating like
while and money was flowing into real
estate so the creative economic
revolution has really been going on in
my view since the 60s and and it's funny
because I went back and looked at this
and and folks might not know this but
what I really wanted to be in life was a
guitar player so all my childhood I
spent playing guitar and and trying to
sound like Jimi Hendrix or Jeff
Bacharach with some degree of non
success but in the 60s we saw all of
this creative revolution weather and
even before that jazz in the 54 but the
beat beat revolution and then the
sixties thing happening in New York and
I just read the fabulous book on on
Warhol in the velvet underground so you
know you can see this stuff building up
as people are tired of and kind of
blanching at the strictures of the old
organization man society and its kind of
you know it's kind of our world
fascinated by madmen I think you know
you see this transformation this kind of
pivot point right running through as
madmen develops and this creative thing
emerging but people don't know what to
do and so the one way I kind of view the
1960s is this giant temper tantrum right
creative people just saying I'm not
going to take it anymore mom and dad I
want to grow my hair long I want to grow
a beard I want to go to California I
want to listen to new kind of music this
explosion in heart but was it really
hinged to the economy and in the book i
said it woodstock wasn't a signal event
of the creative revolution Silicon
Valley is and so I think what happened
almost at the same time as these people
who were tired of working in the
big companies innovators some people
working at IBM and general electric Bell
Labs said no we have all the school
stuff we want to make all this interest
and stuff we want to make the company's
very bureaucratic it's not paying
attention to us somehow they found their
way out to the San Francisco Bay Area
and began to build these enterprises
that they owned in control right they
begin to devise new structures and new
forms and actually Peter my entire early
research career but well before I came
into any ideas of the creative class was
trying to figure out what Silicon Valley
was I wrote a book in 1990 about this
called the breakthrough illusion in any
event I think those structures began to
take hold and this new group of people
who had the ideas began to be seen as
more economically valuable and what's
happened over the past 20 or 30 years as
manufacturing has been offshored in
outsourcing who's moved to the bricks
but perfectly China I think in the
advanced countries like the United
States or canned or Scandinavian
Northern Europe this creative input this
idea input this mental labor has become
more important so I see this shift as
big as in fundamental as the shift you
know that Marx wrote about when we move
from a feudal or agricultural society to
a modern industrial economy in society I
see this shift kind of the same way
we're moving from an older industrial
society where value was created by
physical labor and raw materials to a
new kind of society and economy where
valued more I mean raw materials and
physical labor and agricultural is still
important we need to eat and drive
things and we need homes but this mental
value-added this creative labor is
becoming more important so that's why I
think this is a big revolution on the
order of the transformation of the
transformation from an agrarian society
to an industrial economy in society